Now remember your goal here is to start
with a series of hypotheses, that's all
you have on day one. If you're a domain
expert, maybe you know a little more, but
it's okay because you're just kind of
guessing here. You start with, "Well, here's
who I think my customers are," but then
you get out of the building and you
start running experiments and you find
out, "Oh, I was right" or more often on your
first guesses, "I was wrong." And because
we're going to do these experiments
cheaply inexpensively and upfront, we're
going to save all the enormous waste we
would do if we waited until we launched
the product and did an expensive
marketing campaign and then only then
realizing that oops
these weren't our customers or these
were our customers, but we built the
wrong features. So let's dive down a
level deeper and first focus on what's
the jobs needed to be done. That is,
what's the customer segments trying to
get done and is it a problem or need. Now
this phrase jobs to be done was first
popularized by Clayton Christensen who
wrote a series of books, "The innovators
Dilemma" and "The Innovators Solution"
should probably be on any entrepreneurs
reading list and what Christensen said
is look what functional or social jobs
are getting done. That is, does the
customer want to perform or complete a
specific task? Or solve a problem? Or
trying to look good? Gain power status?
Or there's some emotional jobs - do they want to look better? feel good? feel more
secure? And what basic needs are you
helping your customer satisfy? Is it
entertainment? Is it dating? Is it something hardwired into the human psyche?